c'est ici aux abords de cette sortie de
l'autoroute 20 à lévis que commencera le
tunnel du troisième ligne il se
terminera à 8,3 kilomètres plus loin
près du centre vidéotron en basse ville
de québec ce serait le tunnel
autoroutier le plus large au monde
ces voies de circulation sur deux étages
y seront aménagés quatre voies pour les
voitures 2 pour les autobus deux sorties
du côté de québec relieront le tunnel au
futur tramway
le projet pourrait coûter entre 7 et 10
milliards de dollars
énorme ça manque de modestie je trouve
ça très très bien il faut évoluer
arrêtant de surtout à québec les gens
sont jamais d'accord aussi pour ça et
ont peur d'avoir peur
joseph e c'était un gaspillage d'argent
pour la mettre l'argent à des peines
beaucoup plus intéressante que moi je
choisirais entre le troisième lien ultra
moins un des deux troisièmes à long
terme dans la région de québec où les
heures de pointe sont de plus en plus
difficile l'appui au projet tel que
présenté aussi entre 47 et 60% selon
deux sondages parus la semaine dernière
nous avons demandé une entrevue avec le
directeur du bureau de projet du
troisième bien mais elle nous a été
refusé le cabinet du ministre des
transports françois bonnardel lui va
plutôt référer au porte parole du mtq
selon les évaluations du bureau de
projet mais environ entre 50 et 55 mille
véhicules par jour qui vont utiliser le
tunnel et ça fait en sorte qu'il ya un
potentiel de réduire les débits de
circulation ou la congestion sur les
deux ponts d'environ 15 % l'achalandage
estimé est donc presque trois fois moins
élevé que celui du nouveau pont samuel
de champlain qui lui a coûté deux fois
moins cher à 4 milliards 200 millions de
dollars la gamme les gens québec a
besoin d'une amélioration de la mobilité
et je pense que le troisième niveau qui
en 2015 l'ingénieur bruno massicotte a
eu le mandat d'étudier un tracé qui
passait sous la pointe de l'île
d'orléans plus à l'est
trop en périphérie ce projet n'a pas été
retenu et les geignards pu le comprendre
mais il se pose des questions sur le
projet annoncé
c'est difficile de voir pour commande
est passée de 4 milliards même avec un
considérant déflation un projet autour
de 10 milliards avec tout cet argent
pense-t-il
on pourrait construire un court tunnel
pour le tramway entre québec et lévis en
plus de nouveaux ponts pour les voitures
à côté des deux autres plus à l'ouest
plus on fait quelque chose qui se
tendent à ou que déjà été fait en
premier pour lesquels on on peut
contrôler les paramètres plus on fait
quelque chose qui est à risque comme
creusé un tunnel de 8 km ça comporte
plus de risques et plus de 10 des coûts
plus élevés le choix d'opter pour un
tunnel d'un seul tube à deux étages fait
partie des défis entre autres parce qu
un tunnelier de plus de 19 mètres de
diamètre sera nécessaire pour creuser
aucun d'aussi gros n'a encore été conçu
sur la planète à seattle aux états unis
un tunnel de deux étages a été inaugurée
en 2019 mais il est un peu plus petit le
tunnelier avait 17 mètres de diamètre à
seattle et 26 un tunnelier qui était
fait pour creuser dans le sable et il
rencontre une tige ou des tiges
métalliques et les couteaux se sont
brisés et pour changer les plus tôt il a
fallu creuser un puits
ce que je sache ça retarde et de lune
année ou deux le projet avec les coûts
dans sa note du retable aussi
d'excavation on en parle d'au moins 13
forage qui ont déjà été effectués tant
du côté québec de lévis est maintenant
dans le fleuve saint-laurent alors
vraiment toutes les études nécessaires
seront réalisés pour éviter justement
qu'on ait des surprises avec le
tunnelier selon le ministère des
transports c'est en 2027 qu'on
commencera à creuser le tunnel
qu'est ce que vous dites aux gens qui
disent on va faire un peu en fait ce
qu'on parle d'une infrastructure qui
sera en place pour une centaine d'années
et ça fait en sorte qu'il faut se
projeter vers l'avenir
c'est ce qu'a fait le bureau de projet
en dix ans il y aura du développement
économique y aura du développement
démographique dans la grande région de
québec et c'est surtout sur la rive sud
de québec que le troisième levier
favorisera le développement
ceux qui habitent dans l'est de
chaudière appalaches et qui travaille au
centre ville n'auront plus à faire le
grand tour
on ne la congestion routière nos
entreprises vous l'êtes aussi attractive
et retenir leur main d'oeuvre les
énormément de pertes de temps se cachent
les postes sur les réseaux routiers elle
veut à leur tête compétitivité il faut
arrêter passer que des projets
économiques avec des retombées
économiques si c'est contre
l'environnement face à l'île d'orléans
beaumont est une jolie municipalité
tranquille au résident 3000 personnes
l'entrée du tunnel sera située à dix
kilomètres de là le maire est content ça
va aider par et jenlain merci de
bellechasse la mrc de montmagny c'est
notre développement économique
on est en train de refaire le plan
d'urbanisme pour 2036 2036
ça fait qu on a de la place d'un moment
où environ 350 400 maisons à construire
dans le moment il précise que les terres
agricoles ne devront pas être touchées
mais lui pea s'inquiète pour les
producteurs de la région
une fois le projet terminé
ça va être ça va être possiblement de
l'étalement urbain puis des
municipalités qui vont vouloir agrandir
le périmètre urbain piles se fait autant
au détriment de la zone agricole
on n'a jamais été consulté pour redire
et là il ya beaucoup de terres agricoles
devriez peut-être regarder une autre
option ça n'a pas été fait bureau de
projet pour absolument profession et
gouvernement non plus la prémisse est
que c'est nécessaire
or cette prime est selon elles mêmes
peuvent fonder elles mêmes pu prouver
pour jean dubé professeur en
développement régional à l'université
laval
le projet est tout simplement mauvais
aussi une chose que la littérature nous
apprend qu'un qu'on ajoute des votes aux
gouttières ont créé la congestion on ne
règle pas le problème de congestion ce
qu'on va faire
étalez la ville encore plus et rendre
une dépendance à l'automobile qui est
encore plus forte et l'on va se dire ah
ben ça y est ça donne rien investir dans
le transport en commun
lavez les trop étaler le gouvernement
vient quand même d'officialiser la
construction du futur tramway et
financera aussi une centaine de
kilomètres de voies réservées aux
autobus dans la région le troisième lien
quant à lui est prévu ouvrir au plus tôt
en 2032 ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio canada québec